the minimalists are once again going on
tour this is our tenth tour in ten years
it is called the les Coast tour will be
hitting eight cities across the west
coast of the United States and Canada
for more details head on over to the
minimalists comm slash tour we'll see
you soon all right our question is from
kr earlier this month I left my
corporate job after two years of
planning to start a wellness business I
got certified two years ago and spent
this past year writing a book which is
now out for beta reader feedback while I
go through the self-publishing process
I'm looking to begin the next project
how do I decide among the many options
create an online course develop a
workshop focused on my blog explore
podcasting pursue one-on-one coaching
something else yeah this is a man her
question stresses me out a little bit so
here's here's my pithy answer well I
have three of them actually so and I'm
gonna read the second one first Erin you
can do everything but not at the same
time yeah and and what I mean by that is
over the last decade yeah oh and I did
the blog we've done three books for
working our fourth one now we've done
nine tours in nine years we have done
two hundred and fourteen podcast
episodes now actually it's much more
than that because although the patreon
episodes which are even longer than
these and so we have hundreds of podcast
episodes but you eat the elephant one
bite at a time yeah I mean we didn't
start out and we're like okay we're the
minimalists we've got this website now
now we gotta you know check all these
boxes with a blog with a podcast with a
documentary with books and yeah if we
looked at the whole elephant instead of
taking it one piece at a time then yes
we absolutely well I don't think we'd be
as I don't know we wouldn't have had as
many creations as we do now but kind of
taking it one at a time it has really
helped us to use many many vehicles and
create a lot of things it allows you to
be focused to is a really nice thing
because if we were to put all right Ryan
we're gonna work on these ten projects
you put them all on the table what
happens you put ten percent into each of
them
hmm well 10% doesn't get you very far
that's an F - yeah and so so if you try
to work on them all right now kr you're
going to fail
any of those things that you pick which
them what's the one that excites you
when you get up in the morning you're
like I really really really want to do
that is it a book is it an online course
is it a workshop is a one-on-one
coaching is it podcasting whatever that
is the thing that excites you start with
that yeah and once you've mastered that
you can always move on to the next thing
Ryan and I work on one major project a
year and then everything else we do
serves that project yeah I would be
careful too kr to not pick the project
that you think is gonna make you the
most money so kind of going back to what
we were talking to at the beginning of
this podcast if you're if you're gonna
pick a pop project because you're like
oh this is money I can make this is
gonna give me Fame like if you're doing
it for the wrong reasons
or I'm sorry if you're doing it for
those reasons those are the wrong
reasons and ultimately you're choosing
the wrong thing and Dean I got a few
more pithy answers for you we could put
these in the show notes this one of my
favorites create value not content man
that's the other thing to think about we
don't want to be content creators we
don't want to add to the noise we want
to make things are gonna stand the test
of time they're gonna last the rest of
your lifetime things that you'll be
really happy with a decade from now not
because they're perfect I don't want you
to be a perfectionist but I want you to
be really proud of the yes given the
resources I have this is the absolute
best I could do and knowing that you can
always improve upon it in the future
you're gonna continue to be a better
writer or coach or podcaster or whatever
but you're gonna be really satisfied
with the work that you put into it and
finally Ryan my my third pithy answer is
if you don't know what you want you'll
get everything you don't want ain't that
the truth
my pissy answer is this good businesses
make money great businesses solve
problems I mean you've got to ask
yourself how are you gonna help people
solve problems kr like and that is how
you choose which project you you pick
like what are you passionate about what
gets you excited and let's say you've
got four projects you're like oh but I
really am excited about these four
things then look at the one that's going
to help the most people solve the most
problems and that is how you're gonna
pick pick the best thing to work on can
i pinned your pithy answer because I
love no I love right go ahead
so so can you read the first half of
that again what is a good good
businesses make money good businesses
make money
great businesses make a difference yeah
oh good woman there we go
you